[Music]
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years that you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts you've refused
to die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick that kind
of said it for extinction
maybe so sorry but not today
[Music]
Oh God hey possum and sorry just you in
that chair I think God would have made a
damn fine president you would have
brought a real dignity to the office
you're welcome America
welcome to zombie land life is about
more than just survival we were a family
dysfunctional sure what family isn't
very what would you like little girl I
really like for you to stop calling me
little girl you know what I would like I
don't give a [ __ ] what you it felt so
good to be on the move again oh my god
I'm so sorry
hi I'm Columbus this is telling us eeeh
hey paul blart this your dad oh so she
knows the rules I told her just a few of
her 73 mr. Hoffman
she picked up the boy he's from Berkeley
Berkeley even have weed Dave do I look
like the type of person that would have
weed I'm sorry
hmm yeah have nothing against hippies I
just wanna beat the [ __ ] out of we're
gonna go get her we write it down
[Music]
start talking you first
[Music]
oh my apologies little Elvis is it me or
does he kind of remind you of I don't
like you at all
I think you double-parked one more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get a
ticket it's going on here
what hello everyone Vilas Nene
[Music]
hey you please stop bothering like him
sorry Arthur I have some bad news for
you this is the last time we'll be
meeting you don't listen dear you just
ask the same questions every week how's
your job are you having any negative
thoughts
oh I have my negative thoughts
[Music]
and finally in a world where everyone
thinks they could do my job
check out this guy when I was a little
boy and told people I was gonna be a
comedian everyone laughed at me well no
one's laughing now you can say that
again
[Music]
so Hospital isn't it
[Music]
for my whole life
if I even really existed
but I do
study to notice
you think this is funny
is the joke to you
very one small thing yeah when you bring
me out can you introduce me as Joker
[Music]
send in the clown
[Music]
talk talk fast you first my name is
Sarah Connor
August 29 1997 supposed to be Judgment
Day
but I changed the future
saved three billion lives
enough of a resume for you
you may have changed the future
you really change our fate
[Music]
protects you
I've never seen one like you before
almost human I am human
just enhanced
why do you care what happens to her
because I was her
I can see you're very upset I'm going to
help you protect the girl
because of me
if you don't make it everybody who dies
expect a big pain brother whole body's
the weapon
all right
[Music]
and this is all over I am going to kill
you I understand
[Music]
I'll be back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
lady down at Sardis I didn't get a
chance to walk her bad dragon back see
rare destiny oh it's okay I'm coming I'm
coming
I see you've brought sustenance for our
adventure no it's garbage for the trash
can and you left the lid off get out
here
unicorns
[Music]
yes boss
it's not quest it's just a really fast
and strange errand it's totally a quest
[Music]
still talking dear friends that's
complicated
many idea when we first got together but
we were different people
[Music]
by Antony this is a Martha and Bethany
the suspense grandfather meet you more
than sort of burden on you you're not
barging he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer think he
went back in we gotta go get him
huh what oh you oh my god
you're Spencer's grandfather are we in
Florida
Thank You Milo Walker did I die they
turn into some kind of a small muscular
Boy Scout
are we dead it sure feels good now look
at my thighs okay you have some issues
here the game is busted
who's the game I'm not yet I don't
wonder yet welcome to Jumanji
[Music]
this next venture is even more
challenging and remember if you job
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji is
that barbers boy we're gonna die we did
are we in hell
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the fellas to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity it's
this stupid face you make huh
he's gonna know you're having a heart
attack breathe breathe this whole left
side is shutting down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] tops 8 we're still a team yours
why were they here they responded to a
robbery people gonna rob 660 pounds of
coke do you drive a BMW door to the job
you bring just one other guy with you
did you only take 50 keys to see the
dumb luck or setup
to shoot us automatic weapons
settings Attila to kill
I refuse
to allow these families to be
traumatized with trials and appeals and
parole hearing I'm asking you to protect
them from that I understand everything
about these guys has been company so far
closee Island Rhode Island been had the
21 bridges and shut them down three
rivers closed
[Music]
yeah version of this what he's Torme
found
[Music]
what's going on here someone trying to
see you out
whose cops new better to see that
actively dislikes them
but soon they still protect with their
lives I just leave the truck you go down
this road you're on your own
you do wrong they play but he does not
bear the sword in vain cops or criminals
if you have blood on your heads
I will find you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I've lived in a world of death I've
watched people I've loved died some fast
was a boy some not enough left to bury
[Music]
all these years I've kept my secrets but
the time has come to face my past
and if it comes looking for me they will
welcome death
Oh
[Music]
I want them to know
there is nothing they can do to stop it
[Music]
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no coach that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
vicious I have a little bit of news
don't ruin my morning
it's never asked me to marry him no I
wasn't really asking nor was I love
doesn't always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong
you have done an admirable job going
against your own nature to raise this
child but now she will finally get the
love of a real mother tonight I consider
Elora
my
Maleficent is a threat to everyone but
you are best at
[Music]
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
[Music]
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature we've spent years caring for a
shoe
now it's time to care for your own
[Music]
this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting
to reach dr. Clifford McBride this is
dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see you again
I've recall how we used to watch
black/white movies together
musicals were your favorite I remember
you tutoring me in math he was still the
media strong work ethic
you should know I've chosen a career
that you would approve of I've dedicated
my life to the exploration of space I
thank you for that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
implying for me
exploration is known as a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
you know you can tell when you're the
world's greatest spy lost our sterling
plant sterling
everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard I mean you
got to meet lance sterling
[Music]
thank you thank you - is too much it's
probably the right amount still go back
to working at home it is gonna change
spying forever
it's called biodynamic concealment
imagine if I can make you wait for it
roll please disappear disappear
disappear why are you saying it like
that or effect that next generation
concealment hey you wouldn't happen to
have it on hand would you
I do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure um what can I offer you a
drink
I got water drinkable meal really great
mhm we had a drink Wow diet stuff has a
weird aftertaste
what's the tech um
it worked
[Music]
subject appears disoriented what did you
do it Lance
look at me look at you I can't not look
at you Walter I can see my butt and your
face at the same time pigeons are
everywhere nobody notices them up girl
it's the most perfect flawless spy could
take better unburn me right now that's
it I'm gonna play with you I'm Bert I'm
raising my voice I probably shouldn't be
raising my voice at you I need you to
unburden II Walter you bird it yourself
[Music]
there's this kid you didn't think he
could cut it I figured it was just the
usual jitters I take him under my wing
he was fighting to be scared
Pearl Harbor is the greatest
intelligence failure in American history
this can never happen again
[Music]
I want to make it right
at least some of the boys still wanna
fight
the Japanese are planning something
bigger so what's the target
we believe it's Midway Washington
disagrees Washington is wrong if we lose
and Japanese on the west coast Seattle
San Francisco Los Angeles Oh burn
we got the order to launch we need to
throw a punch so they know what it feels
like to be hit
we're talking about a couple dozen
planes it's all Japanese fleet
this isn't a fair plan
they dismiss
you know that you came to
when people accountable
you'll be able to face anything
why is dream specs way better than real
sex because they come when you want them
to girl that is so true when not done
they're done hello
ever think about all the stuff we've
done and wonder how we did not die it's
a cultural thing we are too bad as
planes like those [ __ ] who raised
Wonder Woman we worked our asses off
we've opened up our own store we'll win
it we're four hundred and ninety-three
thousand dollars in debt I'm Clara I am
going to invest 1.7 million dollars on
you
but in my experience business and
friendship don't always mix you don't
have to worry your pretty little head my
head is not little it's just that my
breasts are humongous you want to be a
businesswoman you're gonna have to act
like a boss you have to fire him what
don't hate me hate mail was her trying
to you witness my introducing a new
product at her launch party she just
wants to steal our idea we don't break
this bitch's back
[Music]
[Music]
I'll punch that [ __ ] in the face I
would marry you if I was in the coochie
those two hours they are very spicy just
a little sliver goes a long way you
peppers are really hot
[Music]
[Music]
through that time our people robbed lied
and killed until one day we found
ourselves noblemen but that nobility
never came from chivalry it came from
being tough and ruthless
[Music]
the real power is not found running off
to war
real power lies in understanding who it
is you're truly fighting
[Music]
and how they can be defeated
[Music]
I know you want to fight but there are
other ways of doing your duty come on
[Music]
do you feel this sense of achievement oh
my god
and then the other tabs do
a new chapter my life has begun already
I can feel the weight of this crown I
wear
I've been forced to rely upon the
counsel of men whose loyalty I question
every waking moment
I need men around me I can trust
maybe could you know my friend my friend
kidding
that's only follows and it fell but I
will come with you
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on man you could get that buffed
out no you can get that buck down
remember knock-and-talk
Oh
hands behind your head right now I got
this I'm gonna penetrate this man's soul
with my heart
what watch sir I realized that you
scared you know sometimes feel how deep
you think you got in your soul I'm done
my humble time oh here we go again he
wants your legacy to be muscle shirts
and body counts look at this I didn't do
all this you didn't shoot anybody
come on cab you know I shot some yeah
[ __ ] me nice trees I never trusted
anybody the man a skinny man
bad boys one last time last time but not
just black with cops too
we pull ourselves over later
you'll write about the gun I've been
telling to ask for year [ __ ] he's a like
HP
bad boys bad what she taught it to what
you gonna do when we call no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you [ __ ] up the lyrics which take a
long time to learn listen carefully you
are now five thousand miles from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean see ya some students
[Music]
with scale from one to ten how bucks my
rig I drill to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station we even get
that you walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean you don't know what's out
there
oh is that
look out there out there is the perfect
lap you see it I think so most people
can't tell Shelby
maybe Lee Iacocca Ford Motor suppose
henry ford ii wanted to build the
greatest race car the world's ever seen
to win the 24 Hours of LeMans what's it
take I'll take something money can't buy
when he can buy speed what in about
speed you need a pure racer behind the
wheel your car ask in miles I don't
trust him an inch we heard he's
difficult
no no Ken's a puppy dog
now whatever it is show now
trust me you're gonna build a car to
beat Ferrari with a correct
and how long did you tell the that you
needed to 300 years it's 90 days
this isn't the first time Lord motors
gone to war we know how to do more than
push paper go ahead girl go to war thank
you sir
do you think you can beat Ferrari
lighter faster
that don't work were nastier
we're gonna make history
you ready I was born ready mr. Shelby it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm detective lieutenant Elliot and this
is trooper Wagner we just want to ask a
few questions we understand none of his
demise the family have gathered to
celebrate your father's 85th birthday
how was it hello the party pre my dad's
death
it was great ladies and gentlemen I
would like to request that you all stay
until the investigation is completed
what can we ask why has something
changed no no it hasn't changed or no we
can't ask one of his family walls is
that what you're suggesting
[Music]
you all love twisting the knife into one
another up your ass oh very perfect we
check how's that
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely eat
you know something spill it
I suspect foul play
I have eliminated no suspects
to twist it web we have not finished
untangling it not yet what is this
CSI KFC
[Applause]
first you must ask yourself are you
wealthy super truth of the world is that
most games someone to win someone think
of this as fairy tale that actually
happened there's confusion over who has
to pay so they drown Joe and twenty
other innocent people and somebody's
making money from it no it goes back to
this law firm mossack fonseca so what
happens next what do we do next it's a
scam that goes from Houston to the West
Indies to some bank who knows where
they're gonna weigh with murder
which is bad bad bad it's such a big
word for being such a small
how does it all work bribery corruption
money loss millions and millions and
millions of dollars
somebody has to sound me along is my
money most of the time we don't even
know
David um these women can't do anything
just because they can doesn't mean that
sure
[Music]
the decrease that that's just the way
outstanding angels you have the new
client who is she I can't sleep at night
I'm the lead programmer on a product
that can revolutionize the power
industry but there is a possibility it
can be weaponized ulema will need to
[Music]
know I'm J
who are you
embossing
welcome to the pounds of agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can't keep up I don't like
that boy you guys are like lady spies
thanks for wearing my face oh god what
did you do to spend my compressed his
carotid and deoxygenated his brain stem
well that sounds painful don't worry
he's gonna wake up unless he doesn't
Sabina runs the ground game sanyo stuff
let's get the weapon before it becomes
every bad guys favorite new toy take her
to the closet cheer her up we're gonna
need some wigs toy
so in the first posit there's another
closet just stop the touching some of
these blows up
[Music]
June are you flirting with a handsome
nerd
[Music]
how'd that feel because it looks like it
felt really good I felt nice
[Music]
good morning angels morning charlie
[Music]
gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most
elite team of firefighters in the world
we must be in our very best what I see
we do no go for extraction
we can get you back to your parents I'm
legally bound to carry it so that's what
I'm gonna do an intern you're gonna be
obedient so we can do our job and when
you do this when you when you go like
like that it's not helpful
those two Daniken's under my watch me by
your man can't turn my neck what needs
to happen this second is you got to
watch your tone little sister or what
masher is coming to rock you work what
just happened I think the baby just
broke your dog so I get distracted I
can't do this job effectively don't you
remember what it's like to be a kid did
we kill you
well now it's a party
what kind of firefighters are you I know
you don't see it but he has two sweet
side
right
boom-boom-boom-boom don't look at me
don't do it it's not such a shot yeah
[ __ ] man but that's what it's the house
there you boys will be involved in such
activities as four games ambush
techniques she's employed upper I don't
think I can do this yes of course you
can
how about comes to a friend come in so
much trouble
- growing up too fast tango currently
celebrating war and talking politics I
wish more of our young boys at your
blind fanaticism
did you know Jews can read each other's
might but how would you know who saw one
they look just like us
you know what I am sit IQ gesundheit
that was intense
what am I going to do no idea good eats
our girl in the house and language to
judge wanna go she ate I tell you
they're nibbling that is the strongest
in the world their mother took me and
she's kind she treats me like a person
you two seem to be getting unbalanced it
doesn't seem like a bad person
I'm the enemy
you know tonight Jojo who a ten-year-old
kids who likes dressing up in a friend
in uniform wants to be part of the class
[Music]
Oh God nothing makes sense anymore yeah
I know it's definitely not a good time
to be a Nazi okay time to wrap it up
just a few more minutes
[Music]
as on my house from space not literally
that my life
yeah there it is
excuse me major Colvin has a theory that
he can tell who's walked in space just
by looking at it is more than theory you
keep your eye on this one so I'll show
you how it's done I'm so proud of you
well being on the moon and back
you know Michael Collins gosh that
Apollo 11 nefeli the command module for
neon buzz so you know that after he
dropped them he circled the moon for
hours inside the module he wrote I am
now truly alone and absolutely alone
from any known life I am it I need to
get back out there yet many younger so
you're just gonna have to work harder
look at you straight arrow yeah never
done anything wrong in your life I've
done plenty of things wrong really
hit me dr. Plimpton said you skipped in
your last recessions I'm given
everything to this program to the
mission kills me to say it but our girls
been pre inconsistent lady whole lot
bored Megatech she's tough cookie if the
lats off not everyone can have override
I'm pulling you out of the running for
Orion no if I were a man you excuse me I
know what you're doing but you can
almost this is not a drill cadet grab a
stuff what are you doing with her I'm
officially beginning to worry
you acting so strange
[Music]
I'm dirt all systems go
what's it like up there only place where
anything makes sense
I hear that after 9/11 everyone was
scared scared it might happen again it
was my second day of grad school next
day I changed all my classes to national
security morning Dan morning Center have
you seen the story today in the New York
Times evidently the CIA destroyed tapes
of interrogations of al-qaeda detainees
I want to find out what was on the tapes
why they were destroyed no paper papers
were getting people in trouble met our
place at our place papers how we keep
track of laws last night I found this
he's detainee number 24 I think I see
this no no I should video they
waterboarded him 183 times everything
they got from him was either a lie or
something they already had if it works
why do you need to do it 183 times maybe
one a report comes out people will
finally see that
I've you mentally disagree with the
narrative here the United States does
not torture dan you need to be careful
here they can't destroy the documents I
can go after the next best thing
yeah they claim they save lives but what
they really did was make it impossible
to prosecute a mass murderer because if
what we did to him ever came out in a
court of law the case is over the guy
planned 9/11 we will not allow this to
be covered antennas to gain Intel save
American laundries written by the
victors you need to change our approach
that even epic nothing could be further
from the Jamaa cracy is messy if The
Times had your report we would print it
tomorrow know if it's gonna come out
it's gonna come out the right way when I
was a kid there was a place
a dark place
they closed it down we let it rot
but the things that live there
they come back now many ride the bus
this far north
you're running away from something
I'm running away from myself I guess
you can hear me you imagine like me I
don't know about magic
I was called it the shining the world is
how many place the dangerous place
[Music]
these people they hurt people like us
these into Devils they are eat or chance
let me tell you
there's a place
you sure you want to do this
yes you're on dear
and I will find you
and you will screen for years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got something wrong with me that's the
first thing to know I got my headband I
twitch and shout a lot makes me look
like a damn freak show cut that out
touch it Bailey I'm sorry but inside my
heads an even bigger mess I can't stop
twisting things around words and sounds
especially have to keep playing with
them until they come out right sorry
she's figured I asked like I said a damn
mess then I started working for Frank
Frank men a private eye boys Frank
frankly frankly Frank Oh
he's the one who taught me how to use my
head turn it into a strength he gave me
a place in his crappy world until I
screwed up
[Music]
does anybody know what Frank was into on
this there's something going down and
it's big and they were not happy about
what he found we find who did this we
square it counts if I figure it out I'm
gonna make him regret it I promise you
that that's her that's the girl that
Frank was following I think she found
something what happens to poor people in
this city was a news yesterday and it
won't be tomorrow where's everybody go
mostly just disappear this town is run
by Moses Randolph when someone isn't
seen for what they truly are that's a
very dangerous thing if the first
inkling of power works power is knowing
that you can do whatever you want or not
one person can stop you
[Music]
those people are invisible they don't
exist if you threaten his work he will
destroy you you're all alone you got no
idea
[Music]
you're webbed up in this somehow and
these people aren't gonna stop it if you
got a head just like my always turned in
things around some people call it a gift
but it'll bring the flicks and just to
say you remember what I said she doesn't
know she doesn't know what don't I know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me everything that happened
[Music]
the first time I visited death row I
wasn't expecting to meet somebody the
same age as me from a neighborhood just
like ours
could have been me mom but what you're
doing is gonna make a lot of people
upset you always taught me to fight for
the people who need the help
most your life is still meaningful and
I'm gonna do everything possible to keep
different taking you all know what you
into down here now about me can you get
it from the moment you're born god mr.
McMillan we done you mr. McMillan please
I was just about to give up when I got a
call from a Harvard lawyer looking to
start a legal Center for inmates on
death row I was in before he even
offered me the job
buta lawyer yes ma'am thank you so much
for driving all the way out here most
lawyers barely make time to call I can't
believe you talked to all my people say
unfaithfully I did I mean a lot you
don't digging in those wounds you're
gonna be making a lot of people very
unhappy
when people care about a thing that much
they'll do anything to get what they
want when I first learned about all this
it was like looking at a river full of
drowning people and not having any way
of helping them
[Music]
new equipment well sir each of us is
more than the worst thing that we've
ever done I know what it's like to be in
the shadows
[Music]
is my dad he did nothing wrong
it's never too late for justice
you don't want kid enough to fight for
me
if we can look at ourself close
we can change this world for the better
we all need grace
we all need mercy
I cannot shoot back
you get you there telling and ain't
nobody gonna take their folks
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're deep with
you're not suggest new I think you're
suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I know
I'm wrong mommy charge allow me to
clarify in a sequentially ranked
hierarchy based on level of critical
importance the disparity between us is
too vast to quantify agent stone the
doctor thinks you're basic
listen pal I don't know if you realize
I'm sorry I major what was your name
benjoe nobody cares meow basically it
looks like I'm gonna have to save your
planet no but thank you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
security
neutralize it see what makes it tick
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there to be quiet how much
longer I keep three even here do you
have your child in that Bank no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not Maya it's
not your child
smells like bodies bringing an old ham
sandwich
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormal
[Music]
yes less question do you know a mutants
are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place this is in the
hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hey my friend I got that kid I was
talking to you about him I'm gonna put
him on the phone let you talk to okay oh
yes are you Frank this is Jimmy Hoffa
let's meet you glad to meet you too even
if it's over the phone our friend speaks
Ryu thank you
only three people in the world have one
of these and only one of them is Irish
I heard you paid ounces yes I do so
where are you going go to work well you
know what is the situation going on now
Frank big business and the government
they're trying to pull us down
you might be demonstrating a failure to
show appreciation I knew things they
don't know I know
you can't miss the big picture sooner
later
everybody could hear as a date he's
gonna go
you want to be a part of this frame
would you like to be a part of this
history yes I would
whatever you need me to do I'm available
he likes the tough Donnie
hey I'm Fred Rogers in here it's a
beautiful day in this neighborhood a
beautiful day for a neighbor would you
be mine could you be mine
please vote you be my neighbor
hello neighbor mr. Rogers I'm here to
interview you it is so nice to meet you
okay full filing mr. Rogers would please
don't ruin my childhood this piece will
be for an issue about heroes do you
consider yourself a hero we are trying
to get the world positive ways of
dealing with feelings
[Music]
like what
there are many things you can do you can
play all the lowest keys on a pin at the
same time
[Music]
you love broken people
like me
sometimes we have to ask okay
and that's okay
the best thing we can do is to let
people know
that each one of them is preface
[Music]
[Music]
let me ask you a question
you think he black you think them your
people for the knot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the streets are war zone
you'll blue now
[Music]
I got I mean to see a little stain a
call this you already got rid of
everyone that could talk the hell are
you doing you broke it relax
all cups yeah this isn't what it looks
get a body cam on but we got a ghost
she's gone
I think side and even bringing about
that payment right over here
let's get you out of here we got her all
he wants is the body camp
I've been shot what you can't be in here
with this the police they'll help it was
the cops they shot me she cannot get
back to the precinct to upload the
footage on that camera the cop and
criminal in this city is coming to find
her what everybody Oh him
[Music]
got a price on your head what you gonna
do I'm gonna expose
here is the system
all that is before
this initial plan
we're still alive are we
you got a choice to make right now are
you one of us
she picked herself up
murders murder don't matter who you are
[Music]